[Musik]
freunde und herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einer weiteren episode von
minecraft mit luca staffel 2 das hier
ist ja der ort hat die musik nicht so
ganz bei mir mal wieder halten
wir alles so ein bisschen mehr düster
denn meine lieben freunde
wir befinden uns ja noch immer in
unserer höhle in der ich in der letzten
episode das video beendet habe im
letzten video ging es darum dass ich
gesagt habe leute sobald ich diamanten
finde endet das video und wir haben
diamanten gefunden ich werde jetzt
direkt mal frei legen so dass hier
nichts irgendwie in die lava fällt oder
irgendwie kaputt geht und wir werden die
diamanten dann auch jetzt direkt abbauen
wir haben ein zwei drei vier fünf stück
das ist unfassbar geil ich kann ihn
nicht aufnehmen schmeißt einfach mal
diese riesigen siegel hier weg wir haben
auch dass ich tief in bekommen laser
lukat den fortschritt diamanten erzielt
und jetzt werde ich mir auch direkt weil
das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr geil dass
ich tatsächlich fünf diamanten habe ich
werde nämlich damit direkt eine diamant
spitzhacke machen und diese zwei
diamanten werden nachher noch von sehr
großer wichtigkeit sein warum erfahrt
ihr wenn ihr dran bleibt allerdings
werde ich mir mit der diamant spitzhacke
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen obsidian
abbauen
es dauert immer ein bisschen ist
allerdings auch egal wer lieben freunde
denn in der zeit wo ich dieses obsidian
abbauen kann ich euch einmal ganz kurz
über die geile black friday aktion bei
mir
ich freue mich euch mitteilen zu dürfen
dass sehr viele produkte aus dem luca -
shop.de gerade ziemlich krass reduziert
sind wie beispielsweise dieser graue
rudi dass mein absoluter pay to die
aktuell hinten mit einem geilen nerone
golf print drauf oder ihr entscheidet
euch einfach für eines dieser produkte
die haben nämlich so eine kleine grafik
erstellt die aktionen des startet heute
am freitag und geht noch bis sonntag
24uhr so schaut mal vorbei im schlaf der
rudi den ich gerade an habt er ist noch
nicht raus der kommt nämlich erst am 12
ich bin ganz großer teil ist ein weg das
obsidian abbau noch ein bisschen durch
die höhle titel oh
mein gott ich
habe euch gerade zehn minuten lange
teilweise eingeblendet weil ich hier
vorne da hinten ich weiß gar nicht mehr
wo genau habe ich auf jeden fall hier
vorne lang habe ich auf jeden fall
irgendwo die diamanten abgebaut und
jetzt habe ich unfassbar viele spinnen
geräusche gehört und mir ist aufgefallen
dass hier einst bonner ist
ich habe diese blöcke hier auf jeden
fall nicht hingesetzt die spinnen komme
ich ja auch keine angst es ist wirklich
ein spind publikum jedoch durch die
kommen jedoch durch aber es ist wirklich
ein spinnens bauen auf freunde ich muss
jetzt einfach rein oder schon das ding
einmal schnell ausleuchten ich weiß
nicht wo meine davor dass ein an der
decke so viele sind hier eigentlich so
viele sind ja eigentlich gar nicht von
daher werde ich hier den gang einfach
erstmal zu bauen und diese spinnen hier
oben gepfiffen das beraten auf jeden
fall einige die hängen alle warum so
dass man die eigentlich an die türken
haben jetzt 34 getötete vorne in der
ecke also es ist wirklich ein spinnens
border ich guck mal ganz kurz bevor noch
irgendwelche die kassenärzte oberhavel
vorbei hier sind gerade drei spielen
habe ich mich selber angebauten idiot
hier hängen auf jeden fall einige
spinnen open artikel um diese beiden
haben wird wird hier hängen locken drei
oder vier stück nochmals die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mir wirklich gedacht
habe ich das ist nicht normal sind auch
die so viele spenden sounds sind und das
erleichtert uns gerade wirklich extrem
dass die hier an der decke gibt schild
haben wir fordern mit leider keinen die
ja man merkt hier vorne
wir obsidian abgebaut
das heißt wir hätten auch hier lang
einfach gehen können egal auf jeden fall
haben wir hier wirklich ein spanner ich
baue hier noch mal ganz kurz die ärzte
ab und jetzt brauche ich den weg hier
vorne wirklich mal fast komplett zu dass
wir nur noch wissen dass es hier so ein
bisschen ja in der vergangenheit
runterging und hier geht es dann halt
hoch wieder zu den diamanten und in die
höhle reihen der sache ist allerdings
dass uns erst mal die kiste ankucken die
fäden nehmen wir mit den eisernen ross
harnisch benötigen wir nicht dass
nämlich mal mit schwarzpulver habe ich
leider kein platz für die eimer kann ich
auch nicht stecken ich lass das jetzt
erstmal hier drin das benötige ich jetzt
erstmal nicht und jetzt werde ich mir
eine leiter auch hier hoch bauen
[Musik]
mit der leiter hat es jetzt nicht so
ganz geklappt weil ich leider leider
leider keine chance mehr hatte kein holz
das habe ich voll geschmissen als sich
die diamanten abgebaut habe die sache
ist allerdings dass ich uns jetzt
einfach mal so hier hoch gebaut haben
jetzt wissen wir auf jeden fall dass
hier vorne
der eschborner war vor gott wo ist das
doch ok auf der minimap sehe ich gerade
dass es sich hier vorne befindet also
hier haben wir unser dorf ist ein
schweinchen und da vorne ist auch unsere
kleine hütte ich hoffe mal das wird
schlafen gehen können bzw
hoffe ich dass wir
schlafen gehen können es klappt
auf jeden fall funktioniert bei der
liebe freunde wir haben genügend
obsidian für ein portal das werdet ihr
dann wahrscheinlich auch schon im titel
sehen dass das heute so ein bisschen so
das ziel sein soll jetzt all
das wird ihr wahrscheinlich schon im
titel das ist heute
ich kann gerade richtig glücklich sein
dass ich in ändern wenn nicht geboxt
haben heute erst mal einfach ins messer
gelaufen bisschen mehr sein schwert die
sache ist allerdings meine liebe frau
nicht
[Musik]
ihr seht es wahrscheinlich schon im
titel meine lieben freunde es geht heute
um das heulen portal das möchte ich auf
jeden fall fertig gebaut kriegen und das
werden wir auch am ende der heutigen
episode machen zuvor möchte ich
allerdings erst mal hier meine bücher
nehmen hier erstmal alles immer
reinschmeißen und werde mir auch ein
bisschen tannenbaum stimmen nehmen denn
ich muss erstmal meine hobbys höhle noch
so ein bisschen wohnlicher einrichten
dafür nehme ich jetzt erstmal hier unser
holz und packen die mitte bücher denn
dadurch bekommen wir bücherregale
fünfstück reichen nicht ganz wir
brauchen sieben insgesamt das heißt noch
ein bisschen mehr holz ich habe jetzt
hier mal einfach zehn stück gemacht sie
sollten auf jeden fall ausreichen
[Musik]
wir müssen uns da noch irgendwas
überlegen
dass da kein bär von oben reingeht ich
traue mich jetzt auch nicht im
vornherein zu gehen ich werde jetzt
einfach mal hier außen rum laufen und
dann genau den gleichen weg nehmen den
sich dieser bär anscheinend auch zu
eigen gemacht hat also einfach hier
runter zack und dann ist er draußen ich
weiß nicht ob ich den von hier
attackieren kann ohne dass er mich
angreift
die checks nicht
okay
es tue ihr leid weil er so süß aussieht
aber er hat so viel leben und er hasst
uns ja auch
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden fall mal meine
lieben freunde ich zeige euch jetzt mal
was ich mich mit den bücherregalen
gedacht habe denn die können wir einfach
hier so ein bisschen rum setzen und
haben wir hier auf jeden fall so eine
kleine ecke und es sieht ein bisschen
gemütlicher aus die anderen zwei
bücherregale sind auf jeden fall zwei
zuviel gewesen packe ich jetzt mal hier
rein nun benötige ich allerdings meine
stücke und wolle denn ich muss mich
jetzt zwei gemälde machen verspricht man
mal wieder hier fig zu übernehmen um
zwei wolle raus und nehmen uns auch
jemanden kartoffeln kann ich noch mal
ganz kurz stibitzen und nehmen jetzt
unsere stadt und die hier in den kreis
und dann in die mitte zwei davon dann
haben wir nämlich zwei gemälde die kann
ich jetzt nämlich nehmen und über meine
bettchen hängen und zwar nutzen wir
jetzt hilfsweise einfach mal zwei so
blöcke damit wird zwei kleine gemälde
bekommen zweimaleins gemälde die sollen
jetzt nicht gleich aussehen sondern so
das ist noch nicht so gut mache ich mal
so dass sie auf jeden fall schön aus ein
bisschen wohnlicher blaue farben finde
ich gehöre nicht in haushalt und auch so
blaue leds und generell leds bin ich
kein fan von aber naja da wo ich ja
schon mal für ihr hättet für die aussage
die sache ist allerdings dass ich noch
ein kleiner teppich vor soll und da
haben wir hier vorne noch unseren roten
teppich und da dachte ich mir nämlich
denen einfach mal mit einem kann ich ja
provisorisch einfach hier so liegen
lassen sich zumindest ein bisschen so
aus als wenn dann auch noch ein bisschen
was wohnlich wäre ich weiß auch habe ich
ja schon mal gesagt dass leute mir
geschrieben am hey die kleine hütte ist
eigentlich vollzieht was ich da vorne
gebaut habe warum brauche ich jetzt
sofort würden eben da alles wieder mit
ja allerdings soll das ein bisschen der
lagerraum werden weil auf dauer ist es
ja so dass wir wirklich eine menge
lagermöglichkeiten brauchen und jetzt
mit dem teppich ist schon schön aus
ich kann vielleicht noch ein blumentopf
hinstellen also denen einmal kurz
hierhin machen und dann können eine
kleine margarita reinpacken oder wir
packende tulpe dateien ich würde sogar
eine tulpe da sehen weil sich das rot ja
auch hier wieder findet oder nehmen wir
doch einmal geriet ich weiß es nicht ich
bin bei solchen sachen bin ich echt
immer über frage ich nehme doch ne
margerite
erhält geil wenn ich hierhin setzen
könnte
da müsste es immer
dann sehe ich das doch eher so
dass ich aus wie es aus das ist unser
schlafzimmer perfekt zu ob wir können
uns jetzt allerdings als nächstes um die
küche und zwar machen wir uns für die
küche jetzt auch noch mal fix ii eben
einen kessel ihr seht auch schon wunder
im inventar ich habe noch eine laterne
und zwei truhen die kommen allerdings
doch nicht in die küche sondern doch
noch in meinem schlafzimmer steht
nämlich grad doch überlegt dass wir
vielleicht doch erstmal wirklich ein
bisschen stauraum hier vorne brauchen
weil die küche habe jetzt auch nicht so
viel wenn zwei so ein paar fest aber die
nehmen auch nie so viel geben einem nie
so viel platz wie man das dann
schlussendlich denkt deswegen werde ich
das hier vorne dann denke ich doch eher
so machen ich könnte die kiste natürlich
auch so setzen dass sie zum fenster
liegt da ist die sache dann allerdings
dass das nicht nur sondern du hier das
dann vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel
gepöbelt aussieht ich weiß es nicht war
das jetzt hier so genau der kanten drin
sie kommen immer gerne einen kommentar
ich möchte ich es vielleicht aber
umsetzen soll ich kann natürlich auch so
hinsetzen so und so haben wir hier so
zwei verschiedene dann sieht vielleicht
noch ein bisschen anders aus ich kann
dir auch so nebeneinander setzen dann
sieht das auch so aus ich weiß nicht
mehr gerne in die kommentare was darf
das rauchen naja ich das erst mal so
stehen die sache sei allerdings dass wir
uns jetzt erstmal auf die küche
konzentriert in die mitte hier in der
ecke kommt die werkbank hier kommen zwei
schmelzöfen hinein fähig ein neues
bretton noch ein fichtenholz brett und
dann hin neben unser kessel die laterne
die ich mir gemacht habe die war doch
hier vorne führen zwei hierfür die ecke
hier ist es noch so ein bisschen düster
gewesen neben den kessel die kommt jetzt
auf jeden fall auch noch ein fichtenholz
brett und über den kessel muss ich jetzt
einen haken platzieren okay die sonne
geht wieder unter sich gerade der haken
soll so ein bisschen das darstellen was
der hebel im minecraft mit luca stoffe 1
gemacht hat und zwar einfach sondern so
ein kleiner wasserhahn ich weiß nicht ob
ich direkt jetzt schon schlafen gehen
kann das geht noch nicht deswegen
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt erstmal ganz
auf den haken die anderen dinge die ich
dafür benötige habe ich das offen habe
ich im inventar das heißt wir können
einfach nun hier ein eisen waren hier
ein stück holz und darunter ein pflicht-
und perfekt dann haben wir zwei haken
jetzt können wir ganz fix bei ihm
schlafen gehen und dann müssen wir uns
jetzt noch einen webstuhl machen denn
ich möchte einen banner machen den ich
so ein bisschen ich gebe viel zu viel
mühe wieder
zwei fäden 2 zeigt dann haben wir ein
webstuhl was genau wie mit dem webstuhl
machen seht ihr gleich meine lieben
freunde wie konzentriert erstmal darauf
hier den haken anzubringen dass also ein
bisschen aus dem wasserhahn sieht auch
für mich sehr geil aus weil das hier
halt so hoch steht hier unter kann man
sich vorstellen als würde hier das
wasser darunter durchlaufen und nun
nehmen wir die ganzen feste die wir uns
gemacht haben in der time wert von vor
ein paar folgen und bauen hier vorne das
holz ab platzieren hier eine fackel und
darunter eines dichten holz falsche so
dass wenn wir hier dann auch noch besser
darüber anbringen es so aussieht wenn
ich die fackel jetzt abbauen als wenn
wir vorne licht durchscheinen würde
gut auch weil da vorne ist eine fackel
allerdings sehen wir das nicht richtig
weil er die fichtenholz falsch ist und
dann haben wir trotzdem so eine kleine
indirekte beleuchtung und können uns nun
mit den fichtenholz schildern auch mal
eben ganz fix so ein bisschen sonne
verkleidung bauern für unsere küche da
können jetzt nämlich zum beispiel hier
vorne hier und hier ein brettern machen
dann sieht es so aus als ob das hier in
die schubladen werden und hier müssen
wir uns mit dem webstuhl was machen dem
webstuhl setze ich erstmal nach hier
draußen bzw neben den erstmal mit weil
ich hier glaube ich auch gar keine rolle
drin habe perfekt habe ich nämlich nicht
brauche ich auch nicht denn die habe ich
nach vorne und ich glaube dass es mit
diesen blüten auf jeden fall
funktionieren sollte denn ich brauche
blauen farbstoff ich brauche eigentlich
hellblauen farbstoff allerdings sollte
ich das ja so hinkriegen zack zack und
das geht nicht
so haben wir den hellblauen vw perfekt
wir haben herrn blauen farbstoff das
heißt wir nehmen jetzt den webstuhl ist
muss ich mich ein bisschen konzentrieren
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie das geht
nicht brauche erstmal ein banner sechs
wolle und darunter einen stock dann
bekommen wir ein weißes banner und
dieses banner können jetzt hier
reinpacken zusammen mit hellblauem
farbstoff und erhalten nun ein weißes
banner mit vier hellblauen fällen das
sollte auf jeden fall passen ich hoffe
allerdings dass ich das jetzt auch so
daran anbringen kann wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe weil das soll an
unserem kessel ein bisschen so aussehen
wie ein handtuch und jetzt müssen einen
daumen drücken denn es passt perfekt
dass die todes krass aus oder
real job das sind alles sachen die nicht
aber eine modifikation hinzugefügt
wurden aber sie wirklich aus wie ein
waschbecken mit einem handtuch dran das
einzige was wir noch machen müssen es im
wassereimer neben den hier drin
entleeren und da
ich bin sehr zufrieden es soll
allerdings gar nicht mehr so krass und
unsere hobby heute gehe nicht platziert
aber noch zwei fackeln damit ihr nichts
passiert die kommt noch eine kleine
sitzecke in hier kommt auch ein bisschen
dekoration hin mit ein bisschen natur
eine laterne kommt hier beispielsweise
noch drauf dass wir jetzt endlich mal
komplett fertig und das hier vorne wird
auch noch gemacht ich will dass das
hobbit projekt so ein bisschen nebenbei
läuft weil wir dafür ist noch so ein
paar dinge brauchen wie beispielsweise
auch eine verzauberung tisch den ich mir
allerdings auch jetzt fix direkt machen
kann das brauchen allerdings auch nicht
für heute ich konnte mich jetzt auch das
wichtigste und zwar ist das das portal
meine lieben freunde habt richtig gehört
ich möchte mit euch in die hölle gehen
ich weiß dass wir gerade mal in folge 15
glaube ich sind ich werde das portal als
auch einfach mal hier vorne hin setzen
weil ich nicht will dass es hier unten
drin ist ich hatte erst überlegt das
irgendwie unsere reihen zu bauen und so
allerdings hört man dieses portal die
ganze zeit deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
ich baue das vielleicht irgendwie ich
hier hin dass das so ein bisschen weiter
entfernt ist weil man geht jetzt auch
nicht allzu häufig in die hölle deswegen
brauche ich jetzt einfach mal hier zack
4123 nach oben und noch einen nach oben
hier auch bamm bamm bamm bamm und jetzt
zack und zack und meine lieben freunde
jetzt habe ich kein volk
kann sich nur um stunden handeln jetzt
gerade aufgefallen dass ich in keiner
einzigen kiste bei mir einen feuerstein
habe geschweige den kies deswegen muss
sich jetzt tatsächlich nochmal kurzem
eine höhere einlaufen und schauen ob ich
irgendwo hier
aus einem kießling
ein feuerstein
aus bekommt wieso ist aha da haben wir
doch den bruder ich habe gerade mal mit
inventar ein bisschen aufgeräumt und der
ist immer noch da ich hoffe nicht dass
ich ihnen jetzt mal angucken werde wo
bin ich denn jetzt
schon allein wenn man oben rechts gucken
wie viel ab geht in dieser höhle ist
wirklich unfassbar ich bin noch von hier
gekommen ich bin von hier gekommen ok
perfekt also ich hab jetzt auf jeden
fall ein eisen block und ich habe einen
feuerstein kann mir daraus ein feuerzeug
machen und nun meine lieben freunde darf
ich euch recht herzlich zu der großen
eröffnung meines
höheren portals in minecraft mit luca
staffel 2 begrüßen ich habe heute die
diamanten abgebaut und ich habe mir mit
den diamant eine diamant spitzhacke
gemacht und obsidian abzumachen hier nun
dieses portale zu bauen und wenn ich
jetzt hier mit rechts dicke
ich war noch gar nicht trinken
der sound war noch gar nicht am ende
aber ihr hört schon
das portal steht meine lieben freunde
das höllen portal steht
wenn ihr wollt dass sich übermorgen in
der nächsten folge minecraft mit luca
dort in dieses portal reingeht dann
lasst einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glocke den mit 20.000 likes
werden übermorgen in der nächsten folge
schon da reihen laufen ich bin zwar noch
überhaupt nicht vorbereitet für die
hölle aber ihr dürft entscheiden ist bei
hin wünsche euch einen wunderschönen
freitag schaut gerne mlu kamine shop.de
mal vorbei
hier findet allerdings und in der video
beschreibung checks kann ab und schreibt
uns in den kommentaren die hölle gehen
soll wir sehen uns